today after going into the season
there's a lot of speculation on for your
future here for your job securing all
that
after three games you now feel you're
like in a week-to-week proposition just
for the job
no i haven't felt like that but uh who
knows i'm just trying to concentrate on
the giants right now put our best
learn from our mistakes here and try to
get better that's all we're trying to do
here at the staff and
go from there
that's jay gruden talking to reporters
yesterday on a conference call i thought
that he said something that got bleep
that's the sound that's made when
someone joins the call so it didn't get
cantankerous no same thing there for a
second yeah yeah yeah so uh
unfortunately there was no profanity
from jay gruden although privately he's
probably letting some f bombs fly just
like his brother would all right we're
drafting folks on the hot seat it can be
anyone coordinators it can be coaches it
can be players it can be anyone chris uh
ask me the trivia question to determine
who gets the first selection okay here
we go shaq barrett mike has eight sacks
this year which ties the record for the
most through three games in nfl history
who does barrett share the record with
i'll give you a hint he's retired allen
he's retired now jared allen fine you're
wrong good good you're right you're
wrong i mean you didn't want to hear
what you meant he retired now and he
played in new york
you want to take a guess at who it might
be michael strahan
go again
joe cleco oh getting caught yesterday
mark gaston
yes so i won no you did i win nope the
hell with you you didn't win anything
wait you don't get four strikes nope you
don't get four strikes okay um
all right so where do i want to start
here this is like one of those where i'm
like gosh i don't know if i really want
to pick first today
uh i i think i think i gotta go with
just the one that i look at more than
anything as far as being on the hot seat
right now and having pressure
going into a week four matchup i'm gonna
start with the guy we were just talking
about i kind of want to put them
together like freddy kitchens baker
mayfield kind of kitchens and baker
mayfield no no no no it's not it's not
pressure it's it's uh people who are in
danger of losing their jobs i mean if
you want to go with them go ahead all
right fine if you want to concede go
ahead no no i won't do that then i won't
okay that's that's where we're going
from that in general because i don't
think that's necessarily exactly what we
were talking about we're talking about
it's hot seats okay pressure cooker
pressure it's the same damn thing you're
on the hot seat okay fine then we'll
start with this case keenum is on the
hot seat it has begun okay there we go
yeah it's you're all in three and even
though he hasn't played that bad okay it
was bad i understand the first half of
that game last week but the first two
games he did a lot of good things the
hot seat talk has started because
they're 0-3 and dwayne haskins was
picked at number what was that 16 15
either way we know he's the franchise
going forward this was a game that was
on national tv and it was five turnovers
by case keenum and some of them were bad
and then of course we know the camera
goes on dwayne haskins so yes case
keenum is on the hot seat because of the
quality or not quality of those
turnovers which were as you're if you're
watching on tv right now the three
interceptions were bad the fumble over
the fourth and one reach over was bad
and the fact that you just have dwayne
haskins behind you that puts you on the
hot seat
i i think that's the obvious one
especially with this conversation about
whether or not case keenum will be
uh will be benched and and you know i'm
going to go in that same i i want to be
a little more creative but i want to go
obvious there's one coach who's on the
hot seat the clearest hot seat right now
and it's jay gruden and reading between
the lines of the things that were being
said by booger mcfarland during the
monday night broadcast after he had been
in the facility for multiple days
getting ready for the game between
washington and chicago i got the
impression that jay gruden is determined
not to bench case keenum and that it's
not going to be something where haskins
plays until gruden is fired and i got
the distinct sense listening to booger
mcfarland that that uh gruden's on the
way out it's just a question of when and
unless they turn it around and i don't
think they're going to it's going to be
jay gruden out the door either after the
thursday night game in minnesota which
gives the replacement a week and a half
to get ready or there bye that comes up
a couple of weeks after that but again
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things maybe they would fire him after a
sunday heading into another sunday
either way i feel like he's on the clear
hot seat yeah i mean i i get you
you're right i mean it does seem that
he's on a clear you just can't you can't
bring yourself to do it because you know
him well i do
that's i know a lot of people and i say
a lot of negative things about them all
the time you can't bring yourself to do
i one like him and two i don't want to
bring myself to do it because i don't
think he's the main culprit or issue
there i think he's like issue number 74
with the things they got with the
redskins i mean it's not him so that's
why it's a double whammy if i really
thought he stunk and he was the issue no
matter how much i like him i think i've
earned the the right now that you've
known me longer that i would say you
know what i like the guy but damn yeah
he's in trouble i think i've shown you
who gets fired in these circles i know i
just can't give you a hard time who gets
fired in situations like these no you're
right
even if the coach is number 74 he's
still the one who goes yeah i i get you
i get you i get you especially when the
team is dysfunctional and is and is
willing to throw out the guy who is one
of the reasons why they're not even
worse than they are that's what
dysfunctional teams do that's very true
too you're right they do do stupid crap
like that okay um it's not a bad pick i
mean it's kind of like i mean gosh you
picked the same team i picked that's not
cool like find yourself and you picked
the wrong guy picked the wrong guy um no
we're not talking about jay gruden being
fired this week but we did open today's
show about we should bench case keenum
so i picked the right ain't gonna
so here we go
my next one and i don't know where the
hell i want to go here with this
obviously i think i'm going to go i
always know when you're buying time well
because i was knowing you guys who are
under pressure as many as i do who's on
the hot seat and i don't necessarily
love the hot seat conversation but i'm
gonna put somebody on the hot seat right
here andy dalton with the cincinnati
bengals all right it might not be like
hot seat he's gonna get benched right
now this week he's on the hot seat from
never being the starting quarterback for
the cincinnati bengals though when the
season's over i gotta say that much i
mean they're all in three and i know he
threw you know threw for a bunch of
yards in seattle but you know my big
thing with andy dalton is he will not
win you games but he will lose them for
you and that's an issue for me when
you're starting quarterback in football
because at some point a starting
quarterback needs to win a few games for
a team and more times or not even in the
great day like seattle they're moving
down the field and he throws to throw a
ball and the ball flies in the air with
nobody around him and gets intercepted
it's just stuff like that boneheaded
interceptions to where i go it might not
be hot seat he's getting benched right
now but his seat is getting hot for he
will no longer be the starting
quarterback of the cincinnati bengals
when this season's over if the the trend
continues
yeah this is the clear upper out year
for andy dalton in cincinnati and i
agree with you they're all in three
they've had a couple of games they could
have won should have won but they didn't
so uh it falls on him especially when
the new coach is trying to assess
whether or not that's the quarterback
they've got rocks over there too who
look good in the preseason maybe they do
pull the the trigger and do that at some
point during the year
i'm going to put tom coughlin on the hot
seat okay because number one the jaguars
have woefully underachieved since
getting to the afc championship game in
2017. they had a stretch of three and 13
from week three of 2018 to week 3 of
2019 they got the win last thursday
night that's fine but this fight that
he's in with jalen ramsey i think how
that gets resolved is going to be as
influential on coughlin's long-term
status as the question of whether or not
the team is good enough and if at some
point look if if this ends up dying down
for now and jalen ramsey stays in
jacksonville and at the end of the year
shot khan the owner of the team realizes
that this is something that cannot be
reconciled between coughlin and ramsay
and you got to choose between the two
guys
i'm sorry but i'm choosing ramsay and i
think that shaw khan will do the same
thing
yeah i um
it's not a gut a good look for tom
coughlin right now definitely not you
know and and hey he's he's uh
had to deal with some misfits on that
team or some guys just with some hot
tempers and personalities and we saw
that last year and i think the way they
kind of handled the blake bortles
situation blew up in their face and all
of that as well i'm not ready to go as
far as you are there yet uh i certainly
don't like the aspect of man that
conversation must have gone off the
rails for jaylen ramsey to talk about
that yeah
what's the executive vp of football
operations doing having a meeting with
the player on game day that's for the
coach to deal with yeah if the coach is
upset about the way jaylen ramsey acted
on the sideline doug marone is the one
who needs to handle it and tom kaufman
needs to butt out and that's always been
the concern from the moment coughlin
took the job that he was going to
undermine doug marone by acting like the
coach and he's acting like the coach
when he decides i mean if you're a
player think about it how many bosses do
i have i have two my position coach and
my head coach and the coordinators in
there as well yeah i don't have to i
don't want to worry about these other
people swooping in and giving me a hard
time the coach is my ultimate authority
and anyone above that in the
organization i shouldn't have to worry
about i shouldn't have to worry about
the gm give me a hard time i shouldn't
have to worry about the executive vp of
football operations give me a hard time
and i think he crossed the line there by
even having the conversation and he
upset ramsay he's created a situation
where ramsay wants out and at the end of
the year if it comes down to ramsey or
coughlin the the responsible player for
the organization is pick ramsey yeah
mike i'm uh you know i don't know if we
know all the details but i i guess i i
lean towards what you're saying too i i
can't argue a whole lot there you know
that you the football operations guy can
talk to a player but you don't need to
it sounds like he really like laid down
the law you can say like hey that's what
the coach does i expect better from you
or you're better than that a guy can see
a comment like that but it sounds like
it went farther than that all right i
don't like that you're making me go this
whole hot seat like it's like you're
gonna get fired or benched or all that
because like the eagles receivers are on
the hot seat they can't catch a cold
running bearer but through alaska okay
they're on the hot seat but i'm gonna go
with another quarterback i'm gonna go
with marcus mariota okay i think he's on
the hot seat ryan tannehill was
phenomenal in the preseason marcus
mariota i know they're one and two and
they won that first game against the
cleveland browns okay the defense won
that first game i mean he threw a
75-yard screen pass he threw the ball
behind the line of scrimmage and derek
henry ran straight okay there's been
struggles there whether it's the week
two loss against the indianapolis colts
or last week like you saw against the
jacksonville jaguars there was no
nothing in the competitive nature of the
football game that's what i look at his
stats are all like like we saw last week
fourth quarter end of the third quarter
the game's kind of over the competitive
nature of the game's over and there he
does it and he's on the hot seat a verge
of losing his job i think for a
tannenhill and maybe not being a
starting quarterback until he earns that
right again as well
all right my last one because we gotta
go i know and this one is fairly obvious
and and i think that john elway has
benefited from the fact that the
ownership situation is unsettled there
are trustees that are running the team
they have yet to appoint britney boland
to take over controlling interest in the
broncos organization but look hall of
fame quarterback one of the best five to
ever play all time
put a team together that won super bowl
50 but two straight losing seasons oh
and three for the first time in years
and no signs of real hope for the denver
broncos and at some point it's just
going to be over for john elway as the
gm of that team and what's saving him
now is the fact that there isn't one
person who can decide in the moment it's
time to turn the page and move on to
different leadership with the
organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports